I don't know - love is gonna be found on
love island but I do know it's probably
gonna be a big hit it's based on a
British show that just started season 5
and this biggest audience to ever the
American version debuts Tuesday on CBS
but we got a special sneak peek
what's up Entertainment Tonight I'm
Arielle Vandenberg your host of love
island and I'm so excited to give you an
exclusive tour of the villa soon this
oceanfront Villa will be filled with 11
singles in her 20s who traveled to Fiji
hoping to find love I'm Kara I can be a
little bit of a flirt when it comes to
competing for a girl that keep is so
real this is the hallway where all the
Islanders journeys begin but it is also
where their journeys might end every few
days the Islanders must couple up or
risk being booted off the island and
there will be new arrivals - I know imma
catch the guys can't go Smee there's
nowhere to hide well there is one place
this is the hideaway where a few lucky
couples will be able to spend a romantic
night together all alone how special is
that
Oh but just like Big Brother that
cameras are always watching and speaking
of watching while love island will be on
every single week night for the next
five weeks I do wake up looking like
this - the shirt and the pants all right
again well love Iceland is sweeping the
world burgers were actually planned for
11 other countries outside the UK and US
including Australia and Germany
[Music]
[Applause]